[Music]
come on in welcome to the ciri place
hello internet welcome to film theory
the greatest sporting show on the whole
Dame Helen Mirren Internet's I know
we're all children of digital video and
streaming services at this point but
sometimes sometimes traditional TV
surprises us and produces something that
is really special enter the good place
which is probably better titled it's a
great place cuz it's an awesome show and
I'm not just saying that because Kristen
Bell has been my celebrity crush since
her appearance in the musical reefer
madness no I'm saying it because the
good place is one of the best most
heartfelt well written and original
sitcoms I've ever seen I can't even
imagine what the pitch meeting for this
one must have looked like but I'm gonna
try so you have a sitcom for me yes sir
I do
it's about people in the afterlife
delving deeply into moral philosophy
sorry did you say moral philosophy yeah
you know like Aristotelian virtue ethics
and candy and deontology
and you expect people to watch this yeah
yeah yeah I mean who doesn't love moral
philosophy pretty much everyone wow that
was a shockingly vivid dream sequence
but somehow that formulas been amazing
managing to both teach its audience
about deep philosophical theories while
also making unique jokes on the subject
it's like who died and left Aristotle in
charge of ethics Plato and a big part of
the show's appeal has been its ability
to shock surprise and fake out not just
its characters but also the audience at
home watching
nothing demonstrates this better than
the first seasons are season one starts
telling us the story of Eleanor she'll
strop a recently deceased who finds
herself in paradise we're told by one of
heavens architects Michael that she is
in the good place in the afterlife
there's a good place and there's a bad
place you're in the good place except
there's one problem here something's
wrong eleanor wasn't a good person on
earth they need me to lie to old people
and scare them into buying fake medicine
I get it man she was as she describes
herself in Arizona trash bag
my memories I wasn't a lawyer I never
went to the Ukraine I hate clowns
I'm not supposed to be here but that
isn't the twist of the season and
neither is the reveal three episodes
later that silent Buddhist monk Jian Yu
is actually a failed DJ from
Jacksonville Florida named Jason Mendoza
is your real name Jian you know it's
Jason Mendoza and by the way everyone
here thinks I'm Taiwanese I'm Filipino
I mean is so racist no the big twist
comes in the season finale when Eleanor
figures it all out that this is not a
good place but rather the bad place Holy
Mother for King shirt balls just now as
we were all fighting I thought to myself
man this is torture
and then it hit me this is the bad place
oh it looks like paradise but it's
actually a filthy dumpster full of our
worst anxieties we learned that Michael
our Heavenly guide from the very first
scene of the show is actually a bad
place architect a literal demon in
disguise who wanted to create a unique
torture chamber for humans rather than
inflicting just physical pain all the
time Michael devised a system that used
psychological torture by placing four
people in a fake good place and having
them torture each other it's a huge mind
blow that when you go back and re-watch
the season again in this context was
hidden in front of your eyes from the
very start
the lack of steps in Eleanor's house the
creepy clown pictures that populate
everywhere the fact that the only
restaurants in town serve frozen yogurt
what's a food that people think they
enjoyed but that's also kind of a bummer
frozen yogurt and that's only one of
several massive reveals that occur
throughout the series it's a smart show
one that's a bit bigger brained and it
holds its cards close to its chest so
close in fact I believe that there's one
final reveal the show has left for us to
discover true the last episode of the
good place just aired and yes I wept
ugly ugly tears at gd's waves on the
sand speech but through it all I also
remained skeptical because if you look
at the series as a whole even up to its
very final episode it's pretty clear
that this show wasn't just the tale of
four humans and a heck demon learning
moral philosophy and becoming better
no this show from chapter 1 all the way
through chapter 53 has always been the
story of one man's eternal torture
that's right well we were all watching
Eleanor and her friends trying to get
out of the bad place and save the
afterlife what we were actually
witnessing was Michaels torture this
isn't Eleanor's afterlife it's his this
is Michael's paternal suffering he's the
real one in the bad place in this series
and if I'm wrong well then that's just a
big old pile of bull shirt if you follow
Michael's journey throughout the series
you clearly see that it's a repeated
string of failure and insecurity even
before the humans come into his
neighborhood he's already freaking out I
was the last pudding shop work whoa I'm
way out on a limb here and I'm all alone
and it doesn't help that he can't afford
to fail sure he got his boss Shawn to
agree to this revolutionary Porcher
experiment but if the plan fails he'll
be retired and not like cool retirement
like taking Greyhound buses to Vegas to
sit at slot machines all day no this is
demon retirement which is slightly worse
my soul will be disintegrated my essence
will be scooped out of my body with a
flaming ladle and poured over hot
diamonds and then what's left of my body
will be endlessly beaten with a titanium
rod pinata yes except you have the
string around my waist but instead it
will definitely be around my genitals
but not only is he having to deal with
the stress of being all alone with a
literal burning ladle waiting for him
his plan fails Helen or figures out that
they're in the bad place ruining all of
Michaels work he had promised his boss
that they'd be able to torture people
like this for a thousand years
instead he barely gets six months out of
it forcing him to beg for just one more
try Shawn grants him one more attempt
good luck with attempt number two there
will be no attempt number three and yet
over and over time and again Eleanor
figures out that they're in the bad
place Michael ends up rebooting his
neighborhood over 800 more times trying
to figure out the way to get it right
and he can't
it is a literal torture for him as he
learns that no matter what he does he
isn't good enough to make his plan work
his dream of revolutionising the bad
place is shattered his life is on the
which then result in him having to beg
the humans for help suffice to say I
tried more than two times if he finds
out we're all in hot water literally we
will be the main ingredient in a chowder
of pain he devises a plan where the
humans pretend like they don't know
what's going on to fool all the rest of
the bad place the only catch is that now
he Michael has to take moral philosophy
classes with rest of um and again this
is another form of torture for Michael
not just because Conte and ethics is so
dry and boring and why did I spend a
senior year college semester learning it
when I didn't even need the credit what
was I thinking
um but learning human morality literally
sends Michael into a spiraling
existential crisis in short by the first
couple episodes of season two he went
from a confident nearly immortal being
living his life to an insecure mask
contemplating his own demise definitely
not a good trajectory for the guy as
team cockroach works to fool the demons
Michael becomes attached to the humans
which only makes it worse because he
can't figure out a way to help them he's
made friends he's growing emotional
attachments to him and yet he's been
lying to their faces about his ability
to help them the entire time it's
torture yet again putting Michael at an
even lower low than he was before so not
only did I fail at getting us into the
good place I also learned the error of
my ways
real rock-bottom for a demon I'll tell
you and it just doesn't get any better
for him for the final two seasons there
is literally no one in the universe
willing and able to help him save
himself in the humans when he learns
that there's a problem with the
afterlife's point system he petitions
the accountants to help
they don't meal be logical the bad place
has hacked your system no it hasn't
how dare you when he calls on the
Leadership Committee of the good place
trying to lay out the problems with the
system they again are useless Michael we
have rules procedures we're the good
guys we can just do stuff even after
Michael overwhelmingly proves that
humanity has the capacity for
self-improvement in the final season the
intergalactic judges verdict is that
humanity needs to be wiped clean who
came to me and said the point system was
flawed and I've come to the conclusion
that you're right now in terms of how we
handle this moving forward obviously
earth is canceled all humans on earth in
and the afterlife will be extinguished
and we will start the entire human race
over from scratch then even when he
finds a solution to that problem someone
better than him takes over and removes
his sense of purpose up a hill over and
over and then Vicky comes along with
this rock lifter thing and just lifts up
to the top of the hill Who am I if the
rock is gone not even the good place is
a safe place for Michael Michael
eventually earns his way to heaven and
is greeted by the good police leadership
committee only to then immediately be
swindled by them now you are officially
in charge of a good place I'm sorry in
charge you're the boss now that was all
legally binding and we all quit
effective immediately so it's all your
problem now go and try to find us no
take-backs okay bye
and again Michael is faced with a
seemingly impossible problem how do you
make eternity palatable for the people
living there paradise is in Paradise if
it goes on forever it just becomes
mind-numbing and boring it's a problem
that the good place committee couldn't
solve and so they just dumped their
problems onto you guessed it Michael I
think this quote from his former boss
Sean sums things up best you won and you
still somehow failed classic the long
and short of it is that time and time
and time again throughout the series
Michael is put into impossible
situations and has given zero help he's
given his dream job opportunity only to
see his ideas fail hundreds of times
with his life on the line he forms
emotional bonds with people on the
premise of lives he becomes aware of and
immediately scared by his own ability to
die he's trapped in a perpetual cycle of
ineffectual bureaucracy even the
arbiters of heaven themselves dump their
problems onto him it sucks for Michael
constantly in the show and it never once
lets up that is the type of torture that
Michael was trying to create for his
human subjects but in reality it's just
him undergoing it the entire series add
to that all the small little
inconveniences with demons being
dribble in their human skin suits those
suits are really itchy for us every part
of my body's either too dry or too wet I
got to say it took me a long time to get
used to the hang of bits gross get your
mind out of the gutter Eleanor is
talking about my testicles and it's
clear that Michael is miserable the
entire time but what's really suspicious
is that Michael is never retired you see
he is captured there are multiple
opportunities for him to be dispatched
with and yet he never is in fact the
whole retirement thing is just a bunch
of smoke and mirrors retirement is a
spectacle everyone would see the flaming
ladles good on your throat then they'd
ask me what you did I need that kind of
scrutiny right now it's an odd wrinkle
of the show that gets explained away if
Michael is actually the person in the
bad place getting tortured you see he
finds himself in a catch-22
they can't kill him because he's being
tortured it would be the end of his
eternal torment so instead they scare
him with the prospect of retirement
until he gets too close to it at which
point they need to make up some excuse
to delay it and get him back on track
with the ceaseless misery and wouldn't
you know it it's the exact same loophole
that helps Eleanor figure out that the
humans are trapped in the bad place
they're never gonna call a train to take
us to the bad place they can't because
we're already here this is the bad place
and here's my favorite part like all the
best twists in the series the show
outright tells us what it's doing in
season 3 episode 7 Eleanor outright
predicts this maybe there's a mega demon
who built a torture chamber for demons
and this whole thing is just him
torturing you when I first saw this
episode I thought Oh
dip they wouldn't actually call
attention to a major plot twist like
this except they totally would way back
before anybody knew what was going on in
the very first episode of the show
Eleanor practically guesses what's
really going on my parents are divorced
when I was a kid they're probably in the
bad place maybe they're being used to
torture each other it would work and
they don't just pull that trick once
they do it twice I think we might be in
an alien zoo or on a printshop no Jean
you were dead they even call back to it
after the big reveal to show off how
clever they were oh dude I told you that
first night that we were in a prank show
oh yeah you did great job man so it
seems like the good place the show was
in the habit of giving up the ghost
before we know what's going on but this
time we
enough information from which to draw
our own conclusions hold me once shame
on you fool me twice well I'll probably
just wind up doing another episode on
the topic now admittedly the final
episode of the show is a bit hard to
explain away under this theory Michael
gets his ultimate wish and gets to live
out his life as a human and our hearts
are warmed as he learns the guitar
without the help of Janet and finally
gets to say to someone that iconic
phrase taken sleep but put aside the
sappy music for a second and let's be
clear here Michael is a human now and as
this show has made patently clear being
on earth kind of sucks and being a human
is a lifetime full of sadness you're
learning what it's like to be human all
humans are aware of death so we're all a
little bit sad all the time yeah not
only that but he loses all of his
friends at the end of the show he sees
all of his friends leave and becomes
space dust he's separated from Janet
sure he'll meet new friends now but when
he returns to the afterlife all his new
friends will eventually dust as well
he'll perpetually see people he cares
about leave and leave and leave but he
never can it's only a matter of time
before he breaks in short Michael's
existence is one of ceaseless torment
insecurity and constant disappointment
he's perpetually forced into positions
where he's the only one who can solve a
problem and even Lee does someone steps
in and does it better than him even
heaven itself tricks and abandons him to
figure out an eternity of unsolved
problems which in and of itself is
pretty darn suspicious since you know
it's heaven probably shouldn't be doing
stuff like that there any way you slice
it it seems like Michael is the one in
the bad place here if the bad place is
truly a place of ceaseless misery and
torment well that is Michael's
experience throughout the course of this
show what it all wraps up happily ever
after right he gets to be human a
creature that is always uncomfortable
always sad and always one margarita mix
away from getting run over by a train of
shopping carts the ending of the show is
meant to be happy but really it just
shows that humanity is the pinnacle of
torture but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and Fork nuggets I forgot to
send a special thanks to Ryan from
Screen Rant for his little pitch meeting
cameo at the top of this episode if you
enjoyed that or
this theory that make sure to check out
him and his series pitch meeting over on
that channel link is right on screen
right now they have over a hundred pitch
meetings for you to binge and enjoy like
I have multiple times and hey if you did
like this episode let me know honestly I
have another really good idea for
another good place theory but wasn't
sure if you guys would actually care
about this show at all so let me know if
that was fun for you and with that my
friends I'm off keep it sleazy guys I
wanted to eat a Saltine pretty dry I'm
too salty going on on a real low note
here